so of course my team set up this
segment joining us now is Andy Davis
ecologist at the University of Georgia's
Odum School of ecology and he's here
with a jorro
spider uh Andy how big how big is that
thing that thing is right in front of me
right here and I'm gonna hold it up for
everybody to
see here is the Critter in question let
me move so you can see it on the
camera okay so that's as big it gets as
big in in the post that I was reading it
said it can get as big as a human hand
oh my God it's moving toward your hand
move the stick it's going to come at you
um it's it can be big as a hand is that
right that looks like a teenage child
maybe this is this is a small one so I
tried to get a a large one for this
segment but I couldn't find a large one
but this so know that this is on on the
small side they will get almost as big
as your palm and that's the maximum size
they'll get they are if you're an
arachnophobe This Is The Stuff of your
worst nightmares how did they arrive
here the jorro spiders that's usually on
a cargo ship and it somehow it's always
coming from Asia is is that what
happened
here that's our best guess and so this
species is really good at hitchhiking
they can they can put an egg sack on a
cargo container it would stay there for
about 3 or 4 months while the cargo
container is being moved around the
world that's one possibility these
spiders as adults can cling to cars and
trucks I was literally driving down the
highway at highway speed I looked over
at my at my passenger side mirror and I
saw a juros spider hanging off of it on
at highway speed and so they're really
good at hitchhiking and that's probably
our best guess for how they got here are
they poisonous or toxic to human beings
at all okay so so that's a good question
all spiders have some Venom this spider
is no different this is not in the same
category as your black widow or your
brown recluse where you have to get out
this the cans of raid this spider is not
going to harm people and it's probably
only going to going to really hurt you
if you try to pick it up with your
fingers and even then it's a it's a
rather shy speed species and in fact
I've tested this in my lab it literally
is one of the shest species of spiders
that we know of where is the spider now
is it still on the stick and where's the
stick did you put it down I still have
it right here and she is just exploring
the stick um I mean some people keep
these spiders as pets because they're so
docile so people some people do keep
keep spiders as pets it's a real
thing so people do you what do you feed
what do you feed the spider like a
cheeseburger I what do you feed this
thing apparently it eats everything or
eats all types of insects and everything
else so when when I do keep some of the
spiders in my lab I do feed them flies
but for the most part for my work I
capture them from the wild and bring
them in and then I let them go after I'm
done with them um these spiders here um
are are really exceptional because of
their size their striking color ation
and because of their large webs as you
can see in the shot here their webs of
this species are at least 3 or 4et in
diameter and I can tell you from
experience in my front yard you can have
a web that's has three or four spiders
all that are all clustered together that
would make like a giant cluster web
that's 10 feet long and so it's the
stuff out of like Indiana Jones yeah I'm
not coming to your house anytime soon
anytime soon ever and I appreciate your
study of these
spiders I would like to keep them in New
York and New Jersey and not have them
come to you know Washington DC or to
Virginia about that they are coming your
way and and people need to know that
there is no stopping their spread I I've
had people email me asking me if there
if I can do something about this but I
tell them no there are at least a
million of them now in the southeast
every single one of these can lay 500
eggs a piece so just do the math and
it's it's overwhelming at this point
Andy great to see you put that spider
back and it's whatever it is great thank
you very much for the opportunity hey
Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere
else